Çeviri: Melis Meyer-Gümüs
Gözden geçirme: berat güven
Oh Elif ya! Hayat sana güzel,
vallahi yaşıyorsun bu hayatı.
Sanırım bu hayatımda en çok
duyduğum cümlelerden biri.
Çünkü ben hayatımı, yaşadıklarımı,
gördüklerimi, hissettiklerimi yazarak,
seyahat edip gördüklerimi,
deneyimlerimi paylaşarak
ve gece kulüplerinde, festivallerde
sevdiğim müzikleri çalarak kazanıyorum.
İzlanda'dan Hindistan'a,
Peru'dan Güney Afrika'ya,
Kırk beşin üstünde ülke gezdiğim,
iş için İbiza'ya, Maldivler'e gittiğim,
dolmuşa biner sıklıkta uçağa bindiğim,
neredeyse tüm hobi ve tutkularımı
işime dönüştürdüğüm için
pek çok insanın imrendiği bir hayatım var.
Eskiden sinirleniyordum
bu cümleyi duyduğumda,
hep gezdiğimi
hiç çalışmadığımı sanıyorlar diye.
Oysa, öyle kolay değil bu
"Bana güzel" hayatı yaşamak,
arkasında emek var.
Tüm yatırımlarını çocuklarının eğitimine
yapmış olan bir anne babanın
büyük kızı olarak İstanbul'da doğdum.
Babamın bir gün defterimde
"Yunan pisliklerini denize döktük"
gibi bir ifade görüp
öğretmenimize "siz küçücük çocuklara
ne öğretiyorsunuz" diye
okula geldiğini hatırlıyorum.
Annem ise kapıcı çocuklarını
sınıfımızda istemeyen birtakım velilerin,
"Çünkü onlar henüz
okuma yazmayı çözemediler,
bizim çocuklarımızla aynı
seviyede değiller." bahanelerine inat,
mahalledeki bütün düşük gelirli
çocukların ailelerine
bizim evde etüt yaptırırdı.
Annem beni feminist yetiştirdi.
Babam ise bize hep şöyle öğretti:
Bir gün, inandıklarınız, fikirleriniz,
benimkilerle bile çakışabilir,
siz her zaman her şeyi sorgulayın.
Ben onlardan alabileceğim
en kıymetli mirası aldım.
Ne şanslıydım ki hiçbir zaman
aileme başkaldırmam gerekmedi.
Ama onların bana öğrettiği
değerler ışığında,
içinde yaşadığım topluma
varoluşum bir başkaldırı gibiydi.
İlk kez tek başıma yola çıktığımda
on beş yaşındaydım.
Avusturya Lisesi'nde
hazırlık sınıfındaydım
ve o zamanki yola çıkma
bahanem dil öğrenmekti.
O zamanki bahanem diyorum,
çünkü ortak noktanın
hep yola çıkma olduğu
ama hep farklı bir tutku peşinden
bu örüntüyü takip ettiğimi,
daha geçen günlerde farkettim.
O kadar seviyordum ki yolda olmayı,
böyle, uçakta cam kenarında,
sanki dışarıdan bir gözle kendime bakardım
ve böyle kendimi
gerçekleştirdiğimi hissederdim,
mutlu olurdum, ta o zamanlar.
Şimdiye kadar dört pasaport eskittim.
Bu fotoğrafımla almış olmayı
başardığım ilk pasaportumla
erken lise yıllarında
çalışma kamplarına gittim,
Alman ailelerin yanında kaldım
ve yabancı dilimi geliştirdim
geliştirmesine
ama asıl önemlisi,
okullarda asla öğrenemeyeceğim şeyler
olduğunu anlamaya o zaman başladım
ve tabii, yolda olmanın hayatın kendisine
ne kadar benzediğini de.
Derken lise bitti,
Mimar Sinan Güzel Sanatlar
Üniversitesi'nde mimarlık bölümüne girdim,
aynı sene ÖSS'de yabancı
dilden derece yaptım
ve hatırı sayılır bir burs
almaya başladım.
Ve İstanbul'da ailemin
yanında yaşıyorum,
zaten devlet okuluna gidiyorum,
bir yandan çeviriler yaparak
harçlığımı da kazanıyorum.
Tahmin edin ne oldu?
Tabii ki bütün bursumu
seyahat etmeye harcadım.
Üniversite yıllarımdaki seyahatlerim
Barcelona'da Erasmus yaparken tanıştığım
türlü milletten arkadaşlarımı,
ucuz uçak biletleri buldukça
memleketlerinde ziyaret etmekti.
Bu sefer yola çıkma bahanem,
okulda öğrendiğim önemli binaları
yerlerinde görmekti.
Tabii, bir diğer geçerli bahanem ise
ileride, işe girince,
istediğim kadar gezemeyecektim,
şimdi vaktim varken bolca gezmeliydim.
Bir sürü kanepelerde yattım o zaman,
arkadaşlarımı ziyaret ederken
ve bünyemi de o zamandan alıştırmış oldum
bu şekilde seyahat edebileceğime.
Ve tabii, o zamandan anlamaya başladım.
Önceliklerimi doğru belirlersem,
çok istediğim şeyler karşısında,
benim için daha az önemli şeylerden
vazgeçersem, her istediğimi yapabilirim.
Gittiğim yerlerde lüks otellerde kalmam,
aşırı turistik ve pahalı şeylere para
harcamam gerekmiyordu sonuçta.
Zaten, hiçbir zaman
ilgimi çeken bunlar olmadı.
Lüks demişken;
Meksika'nın popüler tatil kasabası Tulum,
her sene Ocak ayında elektronik müzik
endüstrisinin buluştuğu partilere
ev sahipliği yapıyor.
Türkiye'den bu müziği
ve partileri takip eden,
gazetelerin "sosyete" diye tabir ettiği
birtakım isimler de orada oluyorlar.
Ben de kendimi müzik alanında
geliştirmek için
iki senedir Tulum'a gidiyorum
ve bu sene sağ olsunlar,
beni bu sosyetik isimlerle
beraber haber yapmışlar,
"Ünlü isimler Tulum'da" diye.
Muhtemelen hiç tahmin etmedikleri ise
benim oraya gayet mütevazı bir bütçeyle
müziğimi yapmaya gittiğim,
bırakın lüks oteli,
cangılda çadırda kaldığım.
Sağdaki fotoğrafta erkek arkadaşımla
bir etkinlikte çaldıktan sonra
toprak yolda araç bekliyoruz,
hatta bavula sığmayan eşyalarımızı
çöp poşetine koymuşuz.
Ve bu, tam da bizi anlatan
en sevdiğimiz fotoğraflarımızdan biri.
Benzer haberler Burning Man'e
gittiğimde de çıkıyor.
Gazetelerde aynı haberde, aynı sayfalarda
yan yana fotoğraflarımın olduğu
isimleri görünce
kendi şartlarımı ve
onlarınkileri karşılaştırınca
hayatı hacklemiş gibi
hissediyorum kendimi.
Ve bu noktada çok önemli
bir mesaj vermek istiyorum:
Kızlar,
milyon dolarlık mirasların
varisi olmanıza,
dünya güzeli olmanıza
ya da ülkenin en zengin, en önemli
adamıyla evlenmenize gerek yok.
Yaşamak istediğiniz hayatı
kendi kendinize sağlayabilirsiniz.
Ha bir de, muhtemelen bu haberleri
yapanların
hiç tahmin edemedikleri
bir şey daha var ki o da şu;
ben evsizim.
"Bir dakika ya, en son mimarlık okuyordun,
Tulum'daydın, Burning Man'deydin,
ne ara evsiz oldun?"
diye düşünüyor olabilirsiniz.
Hemen filmi geriye sarıyorum.
Üniversitenin son senesi,
sabah akşam proje çiziyorum,
sabahlıyorum ve kafamı dağıtmak için
sürekli internetteyim.
Ama o daha amcaların, teyzelerin,
Twitter, İnstagram nedir bilmediği yıllar,
her yer dutluk
ve ben sürekli çizim yaptığım için
kullanıcı adımı "Çizenbayan" yapıyorum,
bütün olacaklardan habersiz.
Gel zaman git zaman, Çizenbayan
çeşitli sosyal medyalarda büyüyor
ve ben basınmışım gibi davetler almaya,
hatta televizyon programlarına çıkmaya,
gazetelere röportaj vermeye başlıyorum.
Bu benim için oldukça yeni ve
hiç beklenmedik bir durum.
Düşünsenize, elimde tam olarak
ne yapacağımı bilmediğim
bir araç, bir güç var.
Önümde ise örnek olarak henüz böyle
bir iş yapan kimse yok.
Telefonumla fotoğraflar çekiyorum,
sevdiğim şeyleri yapıp paylaşıyorum
ve insanlar takip ediyor.
Yola mimar olacağım diye çıkmıştım ama
içimden bir ses "Acaba bu yan yola
saparsam ne olur?" diyor.
Sistemin, arkamızdan
atlı koştururmuşcasına,
mezuniyet, iş, evlilik, çoluk çocuk
döngüsüne soktuğu insanlardan biri
olmak istemiyordum ben.
Ve bir sene süre veriyorum kendime
ve sağ olsunlar ailem de
destekliyorlar bu kararımı.
Bir web sitesi yapmaya başlıyorum.
Seyahatlerimden fotoğraflar,
adresler derliyorum,
sevdiğim sanatçıların konserlerine
gidiyorum, yazılar yazıyorum.
Bütün hobilerime
iş ciddiyetiyle yaklaşıyorum
ama hiç boş durmuyorum.
Ve kendime verdiğim bir senenin sonunda
bir bakıyorum ki
ben bu işten para kazanmaya başlamışım.
Yola mimar olacağım diye çıktım
ama altı seneyi aşkın süre boyunca
sosyal medya hesaplarım ve bloğumda
ilham aldığım, sevdiğim şeyleri paylaştım
ve benim için en önemlisi, sayısız mail
ve mesaj aldığım için biliyorum ki
çok insana farklı farklı
konularda ilham verdim.
Ayrılık acımı da yazdım,
en çok dinlediğim albümleri de.
Dünyayı gezdim,
bir ara, hattâ çok hayalimdi diye gittim
Şili'de yarı zamanlı mimarlık bile yaptım.
Ve onlarca markayla iş birliği yaparak
hem seyahatlerimi, hem de yeni tutkularımı
finanse etmeyi başardım.
Mesela, yogaya merak sardım,
hocalık eğitimleri aldım,
gittim bir süre Karayipler'de bir teknede
yaşadım ve yoga dersleri verdim.
Bir dönem, bir İndie Rock grubuna
menajerlik yaptım
ve beraber turnelere çıktık,
onlarla da dünyayı gezdik.
Müzik her zaman hayatımın merkezinde oldu.
Festival ve partiler ise
benim mutlu yerimdi.
Ve ben DJ olmayı koydum kafaya.
Yine bu tutkuma da bütün emeğimi verdim,
çalıştım, gerçekten çok çalıştım.
İlk başta, kadınım ve
bir de bloğum var diye
beni ciddiye almayanlar,
bana burun kıvıranlar oldu.
Tabii ki yılmadım.
Geçen sene bana
"buralarda çalacaksın" deseler
inanmayacağım kulüplerde, festivallerde
çalmak için de seyahat ediyorum şimdi
ve müthiş keyif alarak
yapıyorum bu yeni işimi.
Ayrıca ön yargıları
yıkmaya da bayılıyorum.
Gelelim evsizlik mevzusuna.
Artık seyahatlerimin bahaneleri,
hepsini bir şekilde
işim haline getirmeye başardığım
müzik festivalleri, konserler,
yoga eğitimleri
ve ilgimi çeken artık ne varsa
her şeye dönüştü.
Ve bir süre sonra o kadar çok
seyahat etmeye başladımki,
artık evde durmuyordum pek.
İşler çok iyi gidiyordu ama
özel hayatımla dengesini kurmakta
zorlanıyordum tabii ki biraz.
Bu kadar seyahat edip
normal bir ilişki yaşamak
pek de kolay değil, tahmin edersiniz.
Ve sadece ben değil, İstanbul da zor
günler geçiriyordu o zaman.
Ben İstanbul'da kendimi huzursuz, yalnız
ve yorgun hissediyordum.
Ve en önemlisi, evde olma
hissimi kaybetmiştim.
Onu yeniden bulmak için kendimi yeniden
yollara vermem gerektiğini biliyordum.
Meblağları uçak bileti üzerinden
hesaplamaya meyilli beynimde
birgün bir ampul yandı.
Evet, ben toplantılar, çekimler için
zaman zaman İstanbul'da olmam gerekiyor
ama aslında, akıllı telefonum
ve bilgisayarın olduğu
her yerden çalışabilirim.
Zaten ayın yarısında iş için seyahatteyim,
kalan yarısında da kiraya
boşu boşuna para ödeyeceğime
iki uçak bileti daha alırım,
hem İstanbul'dan, korkularımdan,
kalp kırıklıklarımdan uzaklaşırım biraz
hem de daha çok yer görürüm dedim.
Eşyalarımın bir kısmını depoya kaldırdım,
bir kısmını da ya verdim ya sattım
ve siz deyin evsiz, ben diyeyim
göçebe düzene adım attım.
Bu düzenin artıları da oldu eksileri de.
Yatak bir lüks oldu benim için.
Kanepelerde, uçaklarda,
havaalanlarında uyudum bolca.
İtiraf edeyim, biraz yoruldum.
Çok eşya kaybettim sağda solda
ama iyi oldu
çünkü eşyalara bağlanmamayı öğrendim.
Yolda olmak sadeleştiriyor sizi
ister istemez.
Neye gerçekten ihtiyacınız olduğunu
en iyi yolda anlıyorsunuz
çünkü yolda olan biri her şeyini
yanında taşıyamaz.
İhtiyacınız olmayan şey size yük olur,
yavaşlatır, yorar ve mecburen elersiniz.
Ne kadar az şeye sahipseniz,
o kadar özgürsünüz.
Yol sürprizlerle doludur.
Ve her yeni her beklenmedik durum, size
hem iç sesinizi dinleyerek karar almayı,
hem de zihninizi esnetmeyi öğretir.
Zihninizi esnetmek, fikrinizi ve
planlarınızı değiştirebilmek,
kendi inançlarınızı bile sorgulayabilmek,
hayatta kendinize katabileceğiniz
en kıymetli şeylerden biri.
Ve yolda olmak,
insanoğlunun özünden gelen iki kötü
huyuna teslim olmama egzersizidir aslında.
Tembellik ve bilinmeyenden korku.
Yolda olma ruh hali, illâ bir yere gitmek,
bir yere varmak değil,
yolun kendisini bir tecrübe olarak görüp
ondan keyif alabilmektir.
En kestirme yoldan,
hızla hedefe gitmektense,
çiçekleri koklamak, günbatımını seyretmek
ya da sadece dinlenmek için durup
molalar veriyor musunuz hiç?
Değerleriniz, tutkularınız ve kendi
iç sesinizi pusulanız yaptığınızda
kendi biricik yolunuzu bulabilirsiniz.
Ve sadece yola değil, hayata da
bu gözle bakınca
karşınızda sonsuz olasılıkları
göreceksiniz.
Evsiz olmayı, bavuldan yaşamayı,
kanepelerde ya da otel odalarında ya da
havaalanlarında uyumayı,
vaktinizin çoğunu sevdiklerinizden,
ailenizden uzakta geçirmeyi,
her ay yatacağına emin olduğunuz
bir maaşınızın olmamasını,
birden fazla kariyer için çalışıyor olmayı
ve normalden az uyumayı kabul ediyorsanız
siz de benim güzel hayatıma
sahip olabilirsiniz.
Benim yolum, beni mutlu eden şeyler ve
kendimce güzel hayat için
ödün verebileceklerim,
sizinki ile aynı olamaz.
Ama sizin yolunuz nedir bulmak için
bir yerden başlamanız,
o ilk adımı atmanız
ve yola çıkmanız gerekiyor.
Merak, tutku, cesaret ve açık bir kalple.
Yola çıkarken en çok ihtiyacınız
olan şeylerden biri de
size inanan biri olacak.
Ve size tavsiyem, bu en önemli görevi
sakın başkalarından beklemeyin.
Bir de, kendi kendinize,
ne hayallerinizin büyüklüğünden,
ne de onları yolda yeniden
şekillendirmekten
korkmamayı öğretmeniz gerekiyor.
Bunu hem kendinize, hem de arkanızdan
geleceklere borçlusunuz.
Siz elinizde meşaleyle daha önce kimsenin
girmediği yolu aydınlattığınızda
arkanızda yürüyenler
kendi ara yollarına sapmaya
sizin ışığınız sayesinde
cesaret edecekler.
Ben de ilk başlarda korksam da
şimdi, iyi ki vermişim diyorum
bu radikal kararı.
Çünkü yola çıkmasaydım
ne kendim olabilirdim,
ne de en az benim kadar deli
suç ortağımla tanışabilirdim,
ne de huzurla başımı yasladığım omzunda
o evde olma hissini yeniden bulabilirdim.
Konuşmamı yolda olmak üzerine yazılmış
en ilham verici eserlerden biri olan
Jack Kerouac'ın "Yolda" romanından
bir alıntıyla bitirmek istiyorum:
"Gökyüzü geniş, hayat kısa,
hayaller sonsuzken, yol özgürlüktü.
Yol dostluktu, maceraydı,
sonsuz olasılığın toplamı,
yaşamın kaynağıydı.
Yolun sonunda aşk vardı,
söz vardı, ses vardı.
Başlangıçlar hep şen,
hep heyecanlıydı.
Hızla giden bir arabanın dikiz aynasına
yansıyordu hayatın anlamı,
öyle bir şey varsa tabii.
Tan kızıllığında, gecenin bağrında,
bir dostun yanı başında,
hareket halinde olan için ölüm yoktu,
tasa yoktu, devinim vardı sadece.
Yıldızların altında, hızla giden
arabaların arka koltuklarında,
kaçak atlanan tren vagonlarında,
çadırlarda, barakalarda,
uzak diyarlarda yaşam vardı
ve yaşam kutsaldı.
Yüreklerindeki coşkuyu daracık dünyaya
sığdıramayanlar yollarda şahlandı,
nereye olursa.
Kıvrak ve neşeli bir caz melodisi gibi
çılgınlıktı hepsi
ve tüm gerçekler hızla giden bir aracın
tekerleklerini öpen asfalt misali,
önlerine seriliverdi.
Yaşam yazılacak bir şiirdi
ve beklemezdi."
Haydi beklemeyin. Siz de
birazcık cesaretle yola çıkın,
çünkü gerisi geliyor.
Yolunuz açık olsun.